good morning gamers it's another
beautiful day
in minecraft isn't that right everyone
ow damn it i did ah
why are you near my meatball go away
i love you meatball but man you seem to
attract a lot of bad people
what is it with meatballs and bad people
ikea tower looking beautiful of course
moocow are you trying to escape boat cow
please anyway today we have a lot of
things to do
we have a lot of missions to complete
isn't that right sven
basically i want to build a little house
for my little horse
he is i feel like he's not getting the
love and attention that he deserves
he's sitting in here with these other
disgusting
things jurgen deserves of his own house
right sven just like you got your own
house you're gonna at least
at least deserves a stable
oh my god get out of my house
[Music]
all right don't escape jurgen don't
escape i need to make this safer so that
jurgen never disappears again
because my heart cannot handle it
anymore
isn't that right sven don't worry sven
it won't be as fancy as your house it
will just be
a stable how tall does it have to be for
me to ride out
okay oh my god this is the most annoying
place to build you guys are in my face
you smell no wonder jurgen doesn't like
it with you guys
oh my god you're good no
i'm trying to build here it's going to
be the best stable
you have ever seen in your life i
couldn't even finish that sentence
without
oh god sven and
his perverted ways do i have fence i do
have pens
there we go i mean already looking
low-key kind of
cute that's adorable
now you're breathtaking jurgen you're
oh we should lit up with lantern
that would be so cute i don't need that
many uh
can i make these back it's for a good
cause it's for a good cause
ah and it hurts my soul it's for jurgen
okay it's for year again buy a t-shirt
so i can afford this
oh my god that's so good cow what the
freak e
dude oh my god i didn't know you could
hang them
that's adorable
yes are you kidding me i'm one
short damn it it's for jurgen
it's for jurgen do it for jurgen smergen
pergan
oh my god on one short oh never mind
perfect oh my god oh there's a cake
oh you know what would be cute having
like a little caldron
caldron are they expensive ah i'm not
making that oh it's for jerking though i
have these stones
[Laughter]
[Music]
guys all right i can't enter now
ah like wouldn't it be cute
if he had this little oh there's already
water
perfect look so he can make a drink
drink so he can make slurps look
can i ride the llamas i can't okay we're
gonna have to
train i don't want to ride you
ah all right i'll push you then
jeez out no no cows cannon
oh god this is an oh god jurgen has
already escaped
get out yes
this is for jurgen only you're getting
smarter
oh what is don't go back in gosh
this is why we can't have nice things in
minecraft get out
oh now it works just go there
you too then then they're bone you can
stay
oh look look how cute jurgen has a
little friend in here you don't belong
don't ever speak to jurgen again
that's right maya look he has a cute
little you can drink water now
okay that's freaking adorbs and i don't
care what anyone says
okay so you may wonder why do i have
this ugly wall here well i wanted to try
out
if i could build like a hidden door the
thing is like
because now when i ah now when i ride
out with jurgen smergen
it doesn't work it doesn't work i
couldn't make a door with like
no they're too they're too small for
jurgen
so i want to make like an like a piston
door
i think because pistons are fun get away
from here so
so when me and jurgen go out to an
adventure we hit button
door open and we go out and it's epic
fun time
okay let's do that i don't know how to
do that let's figure it out right sven
let's use our pp poopoo brain okay
okay so first what we have to do is we
have to cook a steak
i need i know i have okay i have three
sticky pistons
i think i might need more i need these
and i need a lever
probably a new axe i don't my anvil
broke i'm so low on steel
fine you know what fine this i have a
lot of diamonds okay
i think i think i can spare to make an
axe
what level am i 27. i'm freaking richie
freaky
all right enchantment time what did we
get what did we get what did we get
efficiency three okay i guess i'll take
it dude can we talk about how i'm fully
diamond
can we talk about that you guys want to
talk about that you want to talk about
how rich i am
why don't i have so much diamond no
steel because how will this work
let's test it out on neutral ground i
don't know how sticky pistons work
but i think what they can do is they
hold they hold the
the block that it's listen i'm a
minecraft veteran i think i know better
than you
so don't even stephen smeden how does
this work
uh-huh does it come back it comes back
that's epic
so the idea then here again if you could
just stay over here oh god it's going to
be annoying no one goes near you
again no one goes near your um
why can't you leave us alone no you
cannot enter you shall not pass
god i hate you all leave us a lot leave
us
leave us leave us are you asking for it
you're asking for it you're asking
don't come near you will you'll get
freaked okay one
two three no no
ah i'll kill all of you
oh my god you freaked already extremely
annoyed
wait a minute can we even go through
this
ah jurgen is too fat sorry jurgen
yeah you better oh you're just showing
off now you're just showing off
so that means we need three more sticky
pistons damn it i'm poor
don't worry about the yelling sven it's
literally poppy has a tough day at work
how did you get through oh my god
pistons yes it's only one
it's only one steal so we actually can't
afford it i think i have slime yes i do
with the squeeze of lemon and lime okay
slime
no piston sticky piston one
okay and then one two this better be
cool
this better flipping dipping skinny
dipping
ball pippin get away from him yeah again
[Music]
he's evil okay so this will go here
i realize this whole contraption needs
to come further back god you're annoying
if it wasn't for watersheep i would get
rid of all of you
all of you would go bye-bye
just so you know just so you know uh i
think i freaked up again for the third
time
it's my brick day birthday i mean today
thanks for all the birthday wishes why
did i said that that's a lie
okay did i freak up again i cannot freak
out three times i've never freaked up
three times
one two three and then it will go here
and then one two
two three
you will be in my skis
that sucks we gotta get rid of lanterns
okay so this is
how it look like when the doors are open
then i just need to wire it somehow i
got your
thank you thank you keep telling them to
leave
hopefully i can make it as clean as
possible i don't really
get how redstone works
i'm still like i don't know
should i make it go under or above or
both
that does not activate it what maybe
it's better if i go under
you just hit me with a gate you can't
hit me with a gate
gosh okay i'm almost done i'm almost
done if you just leave me alone
[Music]
let me think what how is that connected
it's like what
[Music]
this game makes zero sense look how much
space there is
you're only oh my god the gate is back
are you kidding me i don't understand
redstone how did
okay i don't understand red block
clearly but it works
no no
my wiring oh
god
[Music]
oh my god so why does
this not kill and you know what all
right
let's just try it out now oh yeah let's
uh hide the ugly okay you're again
we are riding off
i guess i needed to close as well i just
oh my god peace and quiet i've been
listening to those sheeps for so long
uh i mean i did lose a little bit of the
aesthetic maybe i should spend some time
oh my god get down from there i hate you
they're escaping
you're so annoying cool literally one
cow is left
yeah again not you too
okay so it will work like this
boom we're out and that's it that was
that was what i built and then we come
back
hit the switch jurgen is safe and sound
and he has
water it's perfect do you like it jurgen
he loves it he said he loved it i heard
him
oh no boat cow smith
god damn it i was trying to get rid of
the boat
my god please don't make a big deal out
of boat cap please
just that's right sven today we are
actually heading out on adventure
because when i went all across the bad
uh i discovered a jungle i know i never
went like
inside it but it's time to go i think i
know
where to go find it okay let's go
yeah come on sven and jurgen it's
adventure as
always i forgot a leash i need to bring
a leash
there's so many things you need to think
about in minecraft at least if you care
about your animals it becomes a whole
different
aspect of the game because you can't go
without
ah i'm really glad i spent half the
episode trying to build a freaking
redstone
it's fun i like it look it's cool
i think it's cool i wish i was better at
hiring the
hiding the wiring instead if you guys
have any tips like let me know
sven is with us sorry i wish sven could
go on the horse on here again that'd be
so cute all right well this is a good
time for me to shout out
represent.com pewdiepie we now have
minecraft merch that's right
support the series support sven support
jurgen
get look epically cool at the same time
all right what else could you want in
life
so the jungle is like really far north
this way
gotta make sure sven is still there
bucket of puffer fish it's doing great
today you look really good today bucket
the puppet fish
sven doesn't like spenders didn't like
puffer fish
it reminds him of when he was in the
bucket a lot of people have been saying
that you can actually put the ender
dragon in a bucket and a lot of people
are also
a bunch of lying snivels
all right where's this freaking jungle i
don't like water 360 over the water
ah never works with 360s all right fine
here come here
come on come on you're against fan we
have adventures we're looking for
jungles
what are we gonna find in the jungle i
don't know that's the fun of minecraft
i haven't even been in snow places yet
are there like yetis
it's bigfoot in minecraft sven i
remember i saw fox for like half a
second
and i was like ah there's water oh
i don't remember i i just remember north
oh can we do it no we can't
is that the jungle we found the jungle
fan
there it is
and turtles are they virgin
hello turtles where are your children i
will not harm them
i just want their shoots all right we're
gonna have to put the leash on here
again let's go
i think you can find like parrots and
like other animals
it's a whole new world jurgen
and sven is having epic times sven we
have to be extra careful this is
on exhibited
what is this what is this this
whoa whoa bamboo
freak yeah i can make shampoo now oh my
god there's shampoo in my
can i climb these oh my god
ow oh my god i can climb
i gotta i gotta go on top man i got
ah oh fine oh okay i see i see i see it
doesn't go
again oh my god thank you thank you
damn this is cool i could decorate my
japanese house with this bamboo
that's so satisfying my god it's
thick in here dude i can't even see
myself
ah what was that don't be scared jurgen
nearly choked myself
i don't know like what's in the jungle
like this doesn't look very jungly
i assume oh there's melons in i mean
cactuses
why am i lagging so much hahaha you want
some
fine we take a little cactus break here
you go sven
here you go jurgen all right we're gonna
have to
do the old technique i don't i know you
don't love this
you're good
here you can stay with puffer fish oh
gosh it's getting dark soon
ah no i should have brought it i should
have brought it are you okay there you
go
should have brought a bed now we're
gonna be in the jungle at night oh i
hear them
get him here again sven
that's my boy hey hey hey yeah that's
right
bone gang good job sven is that what i
think it is
do you see this man no not the melon
whoa the parrot in a temple at the same
time
sen look it's a blob it's a blue one
it's a blue one
hello i am your friend we're bringing
you home how do i how do i tame a parrot
oh my god it's so cute
i love you oh my god
oh my god it will sit on your shoulder
oh my god i'm free i have some seeds
here i'll give you my seed oh you like
that
okay he likes it yeah what's your name
then
claus claus
okay claus okay luckily there's like
melons here
which makes bling bling bling bling
bling long
melon seeds you like melon seeds sven
mint claws
you're making creepy noises oh he loves
me does that mean i did it
or that you just like it he's sitting
sven he's closest with us
oh my god i'm lagging like crazy freak
off
is he sitting on my freaking is he
sitting is he sitting
and he's blue too yes
yes yes that's so awesome
we win at games and this i'm too laggy
for a jungle i have like a beast
computer but minecraft is just too much
look at this man
look at this claws i mean you crazy he's
crazy here
have a little mirror of no where's the
entrance
doesn't that look scary there's gotta be
an whoa found it
okay gamers when you sit here class
you uh you keep looking sexy whoa
i got the green oh this is awesome i can
farm this okay this could be a trap i
don't like this
yeah yeah you sit there sit there
everyone sit
don't die felix that's all you got to do
here don't die
i really want this mossy stuff i can
make like cool stuff all right there's
definitely traps in here
i know how this game works hello oh it's
slenderman
hello slender sorry is this your house
okay i'm gonna have to she believe it
all right cool nice knowing oh god
there's another one
what are you guys where'd he go oh god
there's
levers what where is he oh god he's
angry
you mad oh
you freaking oh my with me
stop on my i'm lagging listen i need
your pearls
you talk to dude you suck oh nice
whoa whoa they all get stuck in the
bamboo
nope are you making
is he making sven noises that's so cute
okay all right we got to be careful here
practice caution
there's levers okay i really feel like
this has to be something
or is this like a random generated
speckle it is maybe yes
okay then there's definitely something
here
why are there three levers oh god i'm
scared
hello that's a dispenser they're gonna
sh
what is that that's a trap
oh my god how do i get past the trap
what is this hello did i do something
hello
oh where did that go
question mark sound like over here all
right let's keep it
how do i how do i do the track
oh oh oh okay be careful
oh i i think i deactivated no please
diamonds and steel i really need steel
and bones for spin
oh my god happy day
i thought i deactivated yeah you can
shoot me now you can shoot me now but
you can't shoot me name
no it's ikea bird
it's ikea birdsven yes
i'm gonna explore a little bit more
see what we can find is the bird like
how fast is the bird
not very fast oh what is that that's the
cocoa beans
the cocoa pocos
how many of these freakers are gonna
i thought it was the bird that made the
freaking noise i thought i was like dude
he
trolls me okay i i got uh i gotta give
seats away as well how do i know the
health of uh mr
melon man okay he seems fine freaking
melons dude
dude you could uh yeah you could be like
cool tree houses and stuff don't
don't hurt him so i think with the cocoa
beans you can actually make uh
brown dye it's like an actual jungle you
sit
oh god i thought ikea bird died he's a
good he's a good sport i guess
freaking creepers why are the creepers
in the jungle answer me now
why is that the same temple or another
temple
are there villages in the jungle maybe
that'd be cool kind of finding like a
town in here
oh my god i'm an actual child wouldn't
it be cool if there was like villagers
in the jungle
wouldn't that be awesome sven and ikea
sven
class his name is claus get it right
gamers can i stand on the
out never mind you snake
god is annoying navigating oh my god
they are all
oh my god two of them don't think so oh
that shot though nice shot though come
on what if creeper
is just like us i'm walking in the wrong
direction
why does claus sound like no he makes
creeper noises
or does he warn me for it it confused me
so much the first time
i think he does it to warn me that's so
awesome klaus is awesome all right we
just gotta find jurgen in bounce
panda panda
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you want feathers no seats
what is he like what is pandas like
bamboo they like bamboo
you like bamboo oh my god that's a cat
[Laughter]
we're making new friends guys this is
awesome
dang you really chug that down huh can i
even tame a panda
you you that makes no sense all right
just finish it
oh my god you're really chugging that
down aren't you
wait pandas have different personalities
they can be lazy worried playful
aggressive weak
or brown what that's so cool
so i don't think we can actually tame it
so i'm just gonna
go ahead and do this meme does he follow
me is he like a cow that he follows if i
have bamboo
how do i make him follow me here have
another one so i definitely got the lazy
version of the panda my god
you are not moving are you so i can't
put the liege on him how do i make him
come
can you move at all or is he stuck maybe
he's stuck in the
bamboo i'll push you all the way back
home buddy
is he following me now ah
research is actually moving now here i
got bamboo
you want this can i ride him
what can i do what can i do with you
lame
all right i guess i can't tame them
whatever we have a real
panda at home okay we don't need fake
pandas just gotta find jurgen now
he's in a hole somewhere um
oh god where did i put him
oh look at the bird claws there he is
yeah again
hello jurgen here
here's a treat oh never mind he doesn't
want it okay
now how do i get out of here this is
probably
the easiest way can they teleport this
far
oh god all right
oh my gosh i think
nope oh
oh he's warning me again oh my god don't
go in there again
i think not oh he's using hacks
oh my gosh whoa
is that it's a triton guy we're going
for it
we're going for it they're dangerous
it's frick sven i need you in hole right
now
oh sorry sorry oh my god i'm a little
sven damn savage dude jargon
i hit him like a million whoa he's on
land
chiba that's good though
yes did he drop it
damn it get him sven get him sven
kill him kill him kill him sven
show him show him what you got sven
freak him up real good sven
nice job sven cool so it's raining it's
raining here but not here
minecraft makes no sense gosh can the
sun come up please
whoa it's a village guys claus were you
flying backwards i saw that
high jump oh yeah kitty
damn it i don't have i don't have fish
one day we'll tame a kia
we'll tame keanu reeves 26 potatoes
you're crazy
get out of my face give me this i want
this
i think we're gonna have to start
preparing for the end game
like getting arrows and stuff like that
because
i think we're getting pretty close not
gonna lie
knock on wood how do you make terracotta
stuff
can i just steal an iron golem question
mark
i mean this village kind of sucked let's
get real here
oh sorry sven what in the world happened
here can i steal
you're coming with me oh we got a lot of
new friends today
okay why make an iron golem they're
expensive you can just steal them
i can't tell if this is bad or good but
you br we're bringing you a new home
you're gonna live you're gonna live nice
and stuff
we have like we have stuff
listen i built two of you two of you are
out there so okay
i didn't know you had to put a leash on
that this time
we're gonna have to we're gonna have to
build a bridge
because i don't think he goes in water
jurgen smergen
how fast can the iron golem go i want to
see that
oh that's right you better run boy you
better run
me and the boy no where'd he go oh my
god come
on no ah
oh you've done it now get back from
there where's
where's your leash dude i need oh there
it is come here come back here
you're in the pewdiepie gang you're in
the bro gang what what
did you not freaking hear me dude i
don't care you don't have a say
this is not a democracy you don't matter
is what i'm saying you will pay for the
crimes
of water sheep someone has to me and the
boys storming area 51
run ow
could i bring claus
uh could i bring him with me when i
fight bosses and stuff like that
did i tell you to stop running ah
glorious meatball
where's my ikea tower
there she is and we we ride in
and we close up that was
awesome oh yeah where did the leash go
no one knows hey water sheep there's
someone i want you to see
this is your new hey
you stay here protect water sheep
that is your duty you can't hear me i
said protect
water shape you can't
protect water sheep who's water oh my
god
idiot back it up all right gamers
thanks for watching another episode of
minecraft let's play hope you guys had
fun
we made some new friends today that's
awesome thanks for all the love and
support if you want to check out the
merch
link is in the description and that's it
for me for now smash like
and subscribe oh yeah
what what you never played two for
simulator
you know it's fun right i'm not supposed
to give my opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay i'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price